in this video you'll learn how to find
the inverse of a function algebraically
so what exactly is the inverse of a
function well what the inverse does is
say for example for you to put like 5 in
for X here 2 times 5 is 10 10 minus 8 is
equal to 2 so what that tells us is that
5 is mapping to 2 that's what our
function is doing for us but what we're
looking for is we're looking for the
inverse function that will take this
output and bring us back to this input
so that's what we call F inverse or F to
the negative 1 this is the
representation for the inverse of the
function so how do we do this well the
first step you want to do is you want to
replace f of X with y so we can think of
this as y equals 2x minus 8 then what
you want to do is you want to replace Y
with X and X with y so you interchange
wherever you see why you put X wherever
you see X you put Y and then what you
want to do is you want to solve for that
new Y when I get that new Y by itself so
what we're going to do is we're going to
work from the outside in towards this Y
I'm going to add 8 to both sides keep it
balanced and then what we're going to do
is we're going to divide by 2 to get Y
by itself do it to both sides so now we
have y equals or if you want you can use
this inverse notation f inverse of x
equals x plus 8 over 2 or if you want
you can divide these both by 2 and say
this is 1/2 X plus 4 now let's test it
out so if we pick take 2 we put it in
for X 1/2 times 2 is 1 plus 4 is 5
see how it's undoing or reversing or the
inverse of the original function also
what you can do is if you graph this the
y-intercept is 4 and the slope is 1/2 so
we're going up 1 over 2 up 1 over 2 and
our graphs going to look something like
like this and what you'll notice is is
that these two graphs are going to be
reflections over this 45 degree line
this is the line y equals x so
graphically the inverse of a function is
a reflection over this line y equals x
now sometimes when you're doing these
inverse functions you have what's called
the domain restriction and we're going
to talk about that in the next video so
I'll see over in that video right there